demain je vous écoute chaque personne
ces jours de classe de francisation la
plupart des étudiants ici sont des
demandeurs d'asile ou des réfugiés il
préfère ne pas s'identifier mais ils
tiennent à dire que le court est
important même si leur français est
encore comme s'ils consentent
ces cours sont donnés au centre
communautaire du quartier honsik
l'immeuble héberge une douzaine
d'organismes si on va par ici
on arrive au carrefour des deux nouveaux
arrivants
au deuxième étage
rémy robitaille coordonne les différents
services offerts dans l'immeuble il nous
explique que c'est l'un des rares
guichet unique communautaire montréal
c'est à dire que tout est dans le même
bâtiment ainsi un parent migrants pu
suivre un cours de francisation au
troisième étage faire garder son enfant
à la halte garderie un étage plus bas
tout en passant à la banque alimentaire
pour récupérer un sac d'épicerie aux
soucis
le hic le propriétaire du bâtiment le
centre de service scolaire de montréal
le cssd m réclament une hausse de loyer
2 222% depuis 2018 le couperet est tombé
récemment la facture totale s'élève à
750 milles dollars en hausse un pays de
loyer rémy robitaille est responsable
des baux pour tout le monde donc ça peut
être soit dire une faillite non on va
devoir tous déménagé il y aura une
rupture de service communautaire le
problème il manque d'argent pour
financer les écoles
résultant québec par l'entremise
descente le crb scolaire effectué un
grand ménage des bâtiments dits
excédentaire d'anciens écoles loué au
milieu communautaire comme ici
conséquence les loyers augmentent de
façon fulgurante alors qu'un processus
de vente s'amorce parallèlement
les employés de la banque alimentaire
qui ont vu leur clientèle doublé n'en
reviennent pas tout ça va être
catastrophique le suédois est vers
lequel zahia ou son doigt par sérieuse
vous vous trouvez du stockage l'espace
de stockage l'espace de distribution
c'est tout un monde qui s'écroule dans
cet édifice là et tous les services sont
à tout jamais terminé le ministère de
l'éducation renvoie la balle au centre
de services scolaires dans ce dossier il
s'est limité à nous dire avoir à coeur
d'éviter une rupture de service sans
vouloir commenter la hausse allait de
loyer ou le processus de vente du
bâtiment la mairesse de l'arrondissement
à un projet de centre communautaire dans
le futur quartier louvain est mais elle
a besoin d'argent et de temps
nous ce qu'on demande à toutes les
parties c'est de faire en sorte que l'on
peut se coordonner pour que le centre
communautaire soit prêt avant que les
organismes de solidarité c'est qu'ils
soient par exemple mis à la porte de là
où sont en ce moment donc une bref un
appel à la collaboration
alors que le projet nécessitera des
années et des millions de dollars ici
julie marceau radio canada montréal